Hi, folks! We're here at CTIA 2011. This is my favorite product of the show so far.
This is Dean with "Be A HeadCase" and you've got a great name and you got a really cool product.
What do you got?
We have the bottle opener case that opens bottles, opens cans,...
...stainless steel bottle opener, hard ABS plastic,...
...chamfered edge so you don't scratch it when you put it on the table.
We're the first ones in the world ever to create an app attached to a case.
Let me open the app for you.
So let's open, you're gonna open the app first?
I'm gonna open the beer and I'm gonna open the app. But first, let me show you what the app does.
It counts how many popped tops in cans.
For those guys that open too many, we have a reset button.
We have "choose a song," any song from your iTunes.
We have recorded, any recording, you wanna make a funny sound?
You could put it in there, we have some funny sounds already on there.
We have "choose a picture."
So the accelerometer inside the opener will act inside the iPhone, will actually,...
...trigger the app to open. I'm gonna open a beer for you.
Got a beer.
OK, we're gonna open it. Accelerometer, kick on!
Oh, beaheadcase.com, $19.99.
So, this is great! I mean, you know, the heck with these fancy designs or anything like that, don't you think?
You really need a can opener at the back of your iPhone, right?
That's right. Listen, you could buy a case all day long anywhere,...
...but this is a fun case, it's a real protective case.
This case is one that keeps smiling every time you pop a top.
And now, where could people go get this Dean?
beaheadcase.com.
Alright, so we're gonna, you know, you got your taps set up. We're gonna have a beer and thanks a lot.